how's it going everybody it's warren and
welcome back to my channel the cosmic
wonder where we talk about all things
marvel and
everything relating to the marvel
cinematic universe and although lately
marvel has been pretty quiet they
actually have a ton of plans coming up
for phase four
phase five and beyond in fact the next
10 years may in fact trump the first 11
years from iron man to avengers in game
and of course spider-man far from home
and in these next
10 years or so in the next few phases
that we're going to get in the mcu we
are going to be getting a much
bigger marvel cinematic universe than we
could ever imagine
and in this bigger universe that we're
about to get we're going to be getting a
lot more
new teams it's not just going to be the
avengers anymore and in this video i'll
break down
each new team that is going to be coming
to the mcu and how all of them will
eventually come together at the very end
of this next saga
some on the same team and some on the
other but first
if you're new be sure to subscribe so
you don't miss out on any of the latest
mcu news and so you can enter this
week's giveaway for a chance to win a
deadpool
versus cable funko pop all you have to
do to enter subscribe like the video and
leave a comment down below
so as of right now where we're at we
pretty much know that there are going to
be
at least eight new teams coming in this
next saga
and that may sound like a lot but again
the marvel universe is
expanding so let's break down each of
these teams the first one that we'll
talk about of course is the most obvious
and that is
the new avengers as of right now there
really isn't an avengers team
in fact executives at disney have
already said that we're living in a
world where the avengers are no more
but of course they're not gone for good
so a new avengers team is going to be
established
now in the comics in new avengers vol 1
the original lineup
was luke cage captain america iron man
spider-man and spider woman but this
lineup isn't going to be
anything like what we'll get in the mcu
captain america and
iron man are sadly gone but we do have
an idea of what the new lineup could be
a lot of reports suggest that captain
marvel and
peter parker spider-man are going to be
the two new leaders of the new avengers
and then of course we have a new captain
america sam
wilson we can also expect wanda to be
making a return as well
doctor strange will also most likely be
a key member of the new avengers team
and rumor has it that jane foster's thor
could be a member of the new avengers as
well
and not to mention new characters that
are going to be entering the mcu such as
nova blade and some x-men so the new
avengers team is going to consist of
some old avengers combined with
some new avengers and so far we've only
gone over
one team and that's already a few new
characters and there are so many new
characters coming
especially with the x-men and the
fantastic four which we'll talk about in
just a bit
and speaking of awesome characters
fortnite just came out with their new
season
chapter 2 season 4 nexus wars which is
marvel theme
and they have a ton of epic characters
that you can now play in fortnite and
thank you to epic games for sponsoring
this video
season 4 nexus war just released on
fortnite a few days ago and now you can
play as characters such as
thor thor and all his glory
iron man she-hulk storm doctor doom
wolverine and more are coming later on
in the season
play as these characters and then team
up with one another to stop the planet
devouring
galactus and you can also take up super
powers in the game now like doctor
doom's arcane gauntlets groots bramble
shield or the silver surfer's board and
more coming later on in the season i've
only been playing for a few days so far
but it is the most fun that i've
ever had in fortnite oh check this out
oh yeah so if you've never played
fortnite or if you haven't played in a
while this is the perfect time to jump
in if you haven't downloaded fortnite
already you can use my link in the
description down below to
download fortnite for free now the new
avengers team is not the only avengers
team coming to the mcu we are also going
to be getting a
young avengers team now marvel has
already begun to introduce some members
of the young avengers
we have harley keener who was introduced
in iron man 3 and then we saw him again
in avengers in game at tony stark's
funeral
and of course as we know marvel does
everything on purpose everything has a
reason including harley keener being
at the funeral and then we have the
daughter of ant-man scott lang
cassie lange in the comics she is the
hero stature who will most likely see
her turn into in ant-man 3. there's also
of course the official announcement from
marvel that we are getting a
miss marvel disney plus show and she'll
most likely be one of the leaders of the
young avengers
and then it's confirmed that wanda and
vision are going to have
twin boys in the one division series and
of course these twin boys are wiccan
and speed then we have the hawkeye
series which is going to
introduce kate bishop and she is going
to take on the mantle of hawkeye
and last but not least we have gotten
reports that hulk lane is going to be a
part of the young avengers as well
so for a group of young heroes it's a
pretty powerful and stacked
group a group that could probably put up
a good fight against the new avengers
team
but then of course we have some
incredibly
powerful beings coming to the marvel
cinematic universe
the mutants now based off of everything
that we know so far the mutants will be
introduced into the mcu
just as that mutants they're going to
first introduce mutants in individual
films
then ultimately they will come together
and form the x-men
this is going to be a lot like the
avengers in the beginning they
introduced iron man
thor captain america and edward norton's
hulk if we count that
natasha and hawkeye briefly in thor and
then they brought them all together to
form the avengers the same is going to
happen for the x-men
just think of professor x as somewhat of
a nick fury
now we will have an x-men team but also
some of the x-men will join the new
avengers
but ultimately the avengers and the
x-men will fight
side by side with each other in the
marvel cinematic universe
teaming up to fight the new big bad of
the mcu
galactus and possibly even doctor doom
with him and speaking of doctor doom you
can't have
doctor doom without the fantastic four
marvel's
first family a team that everybody has
been waiting to make their way over to
the mcu for a very long time and finally
they are making their way to the mcu in
fact recently we've gotten news about
the fantastic four marvel studios
registered a production company which is
believed to be for the fantastic four
meaning production on the fantastic four
could start a lot sooner than we think
of course the fantastic four consists of
reed richards aka
mr fantastic sue storm aka the invisible
woman who of course would go on to marry
reed richards
then we have johnny storm the human
torch and brother of sue storm
and of course ben grimm the thing and
best friend
of reed richards as of right now we have
no official news on who the cast members
could be for this film but
right now the fans are fan casting
married couple john krasinski
and emily blunt as mr fantastic and the
invisible woman fans would also like to
see
zac efron play the human torch and the
rock play the thing
which would be quite a fitting role for
the rock
ultimately the fantastic four will go on
to join the x-men and the avengers in
battle
most likely in the next avengers in-game
level event that marvel has in store for
us
avengers secret wars if you thought
avengers infinity war
and in-game were big wait till you see
secret wars
another group that we have coming is a
group that not a lot of people consider
to be their own team
but they are the eternals the eternals
are
almost gods they're immortal beings
created by the celestial gods the
eternals has an
absolute star-studded cast and they're
not going to just be around for only one
film
the eternals job is to protect the earth
and when the earth gets threatened
and it's too much for them to handle
they'll have to unite with the avengers
the fantastic four and the x-men as well
and of course another group that we
absolutely love
the guardians of the galaxy just as the
guardians teamed up with the avengers
and avengers infinity war and
end game they'll do so again in secret
wars and with
guardians of the galaxy 3 confirmed
we're wondering just who the team is
going to be
with rumors that rocket raccoon could be
dying in the film
and of course the teaser for adam
warlock at the end of guardians vol 2.
and then these next two teams are going
to be a little bit different than
anything marvel has really done before
they're going to be a little bit darker
one new team that is coming is the
midnight
suns with the official announcement from
marvel studios that blade is going to be
coming to the mcu blade is going to
start
marvel's monster verse this will include
vampires werewolves and any other
monsters that you could probably think
of
but blade is not going to be alone in
fighting these monsters he's going to
have a team of his own
now in the comics the midnight suns team
consists of
hellstrom jennifer kale morbius werewolf
by night
doctor strange ghost riders danny ketch
and brother
johnny blaze obviously this is going to
be a little bit different in the mcu but
we know blade is going to be a part of
it doctor strange is most likely going
to join as well and there have been a
lot of rumors going around recently that
ghost rider is going to be making his
appearance in the mcu
pretty soon but the midnight suns aren't
going to be the only dark
superhero team in the marvel cinematic
universe as we've known for a while the
thunderbolts are going to be coming to
the mcu as well
the team will most likely consist of
thunderbolt ross as red hulk and the
person in charge of the thunderbolts
taskmaster and possibly yelena bilova
from black widow depending on how that
movie plays out
ghost from ant-man and the wasp and
justin hammer from iron man 2.
and not to mention baron zemo who of
course is going to be coming back in the
falcon and the winter soldier
so right now as you can see there are
plenty of new characters coming in these
new teams to the marvel cinematic
universe
marvel is going for bigger and better
during this next saga over the next 10
years
of course it won't be as nostalgic as
the first 10 years but
it's exciting nonetheless so let me know
which team you are most
excited for to enter the marvel
cinematic universe be sure to let me
know who's your favorite in the comments
down below
don't forget to like the video and
subscribe so you can stay up to date on
all the latest
mcu news for live updates you can follow
me on twitter and
instagram and as always thank you all so
much for watching
woof